A deleted final showdown for Black Widow,
and more Red Guardian, Taskmaster, and Yelena
moments were all cut from the final version
of the movie.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video, I'm revealing all the deleted
scenes from Black Widow, a post-credits moment
that teased Natasha's return from the dead,
plus the Avenger cameo you never got to see!
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
The Black Widow post-credits scene sees Yelena
visiting Natasha's tombstone in Ohio and as
she mourns her sister she whistles softly.
(WHISTLES LONG NOTE)
This is the same whistle the sisters used
to call to each other as children and which
they also did as they parted at the end of
the movie.
(WHISTLES LONG NOTE)
In the end-credits scene, after Yelena whistles
there's a brief pause as if she waits or hopes
for a response, as do we, but there isn't
one.
However, Black Widow director Cate Shortland
has now revealed in an interview with Variety
that there were discussions about including
a whistle reply in the scene.
Natasha, of course, died in Endgame when she
gave her life in return for the Soul Stone
and, together with Tony Stark, she's one of
the few Avengers that have so far remained
dead in the MCU.
If Yelena had heard a reply to her whistle,
even if it seemed like it wasn't real and
she'd imagined it, then I expect it would
have fuelled lots of speculation that Natasha
could soon return in an upcoming MCU project,
similar to some fans' wishful hoping about
Iron Man's hammer sound at the end of Endgame.
Many other dead Marvel characters have already
made a return to the MCU including Vision
and Loki, albeit in different versions or
timelines,
and even Coulson was reanimated for Agents
of SHIELD after Loki killed him in The Avengers,
so I wouldn't be totally opposed to the OG
Black Widow returning if it was done in the
right way.
After all, we don't know exactly what happens
to a character when they go the MCU version
of the Soul World and whether there's any
way they could be retrieved.
Thanos saw and spoke to a young version of
dead Gamora after he snapped, a hint that
the Soul World could be accessible perhaps.
Of course, there'd be many fans who'd love
for Natasha to return in a Black Widow sequel
or even a different movie,
and I think that including the whistle response
would have given fans the impression that
Marvel was committed to doing that in some
way, which is my guess for why they ultimately
didn't do it.
Leave a thumbs-up if you wish there'd been
a whistle response and let me know whether
you think Natasha should come back from the
dead.
The main events of the movie culminate with
Team Natasha taking out Dreykov, liberating
his brainwashed widows, and crashing the airborne
Red Room to the ground.
As Secretary Ross together with a large military
convoy heads towards the crash site, Nat sends
her adoptive family and the Red Room survivors
away, while she waits to face the music alone.
What exactly happens next is left to our imagination
as the film cuts to black before returning
with an epilogue scene set two weeks later
that shows Natasha is still free.
Footage from the Black Widow trailers, however,
indicates that originally there was an alternate
or extended version of this ending where Ross
gets out to survey the scene together with
his SWAT team from the beginning of the movie.
You can see from the Hungarian writing on
the truck behind Ross that the Red Room appeared
to crash down somewhere in Hungary, perhaps
even near Budapest.
There's also deleted footage in the trailers
of armed marksmen emerging from cars and scores
of military personnel taking up positions
among the wreckage of the Red Room with their
sights presumably set on Natasha.
It seems that this would have been an almost
impossible situation for Natasha to escape
from by herself although given some of the
crazy fun action in the movie,
it's not unfeasible to think she might have
found a way out, given she and Hawkeye survived
a shootout with the Hungarian Special Forces
many years earlier.
It's also possible that she somehow struck
a deal with Ross or tricked him again in some
way though I don't think he'd be especially
amenable to a negotiation.
There were some great moments with David Harbour's
Red Guardian while he's locked up in the Russian
prison and we find him bragging about the
supposed battles he had with Captain America!
What year was this?
Like, '83, '84.
Captain America was still frozen in ice then.
And the prison break when Natasha and Yelena
come to rescue him originally included more
extensive Red Guardian combat scenes.
The marketing materials show him fighting
other prisoners who got out after a prison
riot kicked off.
And in some behind-the-scenes footage, we
can also see Alexei fighting off a pack of
prison guards, whereas in the final version
Red Guardian's only encounter with a guard
is while he's climbing up one of the walls.
I suspect the longer prison fight was cut
for time given the final movie was already
around two hours and a quarter, though personally
I never felt the film dragged.
Some more Red Guardian moments from the trailers
that didn't make it into the final movie,
include Alexei flexing and admiring his muscles
in Melina's bathroom which is deleted from
the scene where he decides to put on his old
Red Guardian suit.
We also don't get to see him putting on his
helmet as he does here in the promos.
And Alexei's reaction after he leaves the
bathroom with his costume on is noticeably
different in the trailer compared to the final
movie.
Still fits!
Still fits.
Speaking to Inverse, director Cate Shortland
said that there was a good deal of improvisation
on set, especially during the dinner table
reunion.
And I found some more dialogue by Alexei for
that scene in the trailers that wasn't used
in the final film.
Back together again.
You got fat.
It's mainly water weight.
In the final version of the movie, this is
how that exchange goes instead:
You got fat.
But still good.
I just got out of prison.
I, uh...
I have a lot of energy.
Oh!
Please don't do that.
Also in the trailers, but not in the final
film, is footage of Taskmaster watching Black
Widow fight and analysing her moves.
His call sign's Taskmaster.
And that line from Yelena did not make it
into the final film either.
By the way, the footage from that cut scene
is actually taken from Natasha's hallway fight
in Iron Man 2.
In the final movie, Taskmaster analyses Natasha's
moves during the fight on the bridge rather
than in advance and, instead, we see the antagonist
studying a Hawkeye fight scene, which sets
up the Taskmaster arrow attack on Nat and
Yelena in Budapest.
There's also a small piece of dialogue that
Dreykov appears to say to Taskmaster in the
trailers that wasn't in the final film.
Bring her...
home.
This appears to imply that originally part
of Taskmaster's mission was to capture Natasha
or Yelena and take her to the Red Room, rather
than just retrieve the antidote vials which
seemed to be her main mission in the finished
film.
The story of who was underneath the mask and
how she was part of Natasha's red ledger fitted
well with the overall theme of the movie about
the abuse of girls and women.
However, I think the movie's promotional material
led many fans to believe Taskmaster was going
to be a much bigger villain, for example,
the way one trailer was cut even implied that
Taskmaster was going to be the big bad rather
than Dreykov.
His call sign's Taskmaster.
He controls the Red Room.
I really enjoyed the film;
however, the marketing may well have set the
wrong expectations for fans going in to the
movie when it came to Taskmaster's role.
Natasha and Yelena also had some deleted and
alternate versions of their scenes in Budapest.
After their fight in the apartment, this quip
from Natasha was cut from the final movie.
It's good to see you too sis.
And then there's a line from Yelena that appeared
in lot of the promos for the film.
Natasha my sister, after all this time, what
brings you home?
I can see why this was cut as it doesn't make
a lot of sense in the movie given that it
was Yelena who sent Natasha the vials of antidote
together with their childhood photo in the
first place, so Yelena already knew why Natasha
had come home.
And there's also a line deleted from Yelena's
dialogue about what she imagined Natasha's
life would have been like in America.
You're thinking about moving, but you're waiting
for the interest rates to go down.
We did get to briefly see some of the Red
Room widows training in unison after Team
Natasha arrived on the floating platform.
However, as you might expect for any big film
like this and as we can see from the trailers,
a lot more footage was shot of the Widows'
training choreography that didn't make it
into the final cut.
And a cameo by Tony Stark was also apparently
on the cards according to a September 2019
Deadline report from the Saturn Awards where
it was stated that,
"Downey will be seen in the role of Stark
one more time in the Marvel prequel Black
Widow."
Clearly Tony Stark wasn't in the movie, although
Yelena did mention him at one point as one
of Natasha's Avenger scientist friends who
she thought could help analyse the mind-control
antidote formula.
Why don't you take it to one of your super-scientist
friends?
Tony Stark, maybe?
Given their final words in Civil War though,
I doubt they'd have been on speaking terms
during the main events of the Black Widow,
so I don't think it would have made a lot
of sense for him to appear in the film.
T'Challa told Ross what you did, so...
they're coming for you.
I'm not the one that needs to watch their
back.
Still, possible scenarios where he might have
fit would have been via a flashback or reusing
footage from a previous movie, like when Thor:
Ragnarok used an Age of Ultron clip of Natasha
to calm the Hulk and bring back Banner.
Alternately, Tony could have been a voice
over the phone, similar to how Hawkeye's voice
was in the movie during the flashback to the
assassination attempt on Dreykov.
BARTON: (ON RADIO) We need confirmation Dreykov's
in the building.
Since recording this video, Cate Shortland
has revealed in an interview with Games Radar
that initially there were discussions about
whether any of the other Avengers or existing
Marvel characters should be included in the
movie, but in the end both she and Kevin Feige
agreed that,
"She doesn't need the boys.
We didn't want it to feel like she needs the
support.
We want her to stand alone.
And she does."
And if you want to see all the Black Widow
connections to the MCU which did make it in
to the final movie, things you missed in the
post-credits scenes, and the secret link between
Bucky and the Red Room, tap here to watch
my Black Widow MCU Changes video or follow
the link in the video description.
So, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been in the final movie?
And do you think we'll ever see Black Widow
again on screen?
Comment with your thoughts below and if you
enjoyed this then do like and share the video,
I really appreciate it.
You can tap left for my full Black Widow breakdown
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!